[Music]
all right let's go out to California a
and talk to the extraordinary Emily
what's up Emily hey how's it going
paryan what are you up to good I'm
hiding in my car
so just loud and proud it loud and proud
it roll down the windows and let them
know what's up all right so I'll just
start with my question and then yeah if
you have questions you can interrupt me
but um so my question is am I wrong in
not showing my emotions to others and
then just to explain that a little bit I
wrote um I'm pretty I'm a pretty
even-tempered person I don't have like
big varry in my emotions like either
happy or sad I'm just pretty even killed
and more specifically when I do have
emotions I don't really show them to
others I'm more private with them um and
I just feel like this seems to be
abnormal for like girls in general um
but I've been this place since I can
remember like since I was a teenager but
recently me and my husband we sat down
with someone and we talked for with him
for about an hour and at the end of the
hour he made some comment and he said
that he pegs me for someone that doesn't
show much emotion and for some reason
having a stranger tell me that and Peg
me so easily bothered me so I would like
to get your Insight on that well I don't
know that it was
like I don't think he was like you know
uh like working at hog horts I if he
talked to you for an hour and you
talking about some heavy things and you
didn't show emotion he was just
commenting on uh you don't show emotion
maybe that's true so it's not like he
was like you know what I mean like uh so
let me ask you this where did you learn
to be even
Keel I don't I don't know I knew you was
going to ask that and so I was I was
actually talking to my sister about it I
don't know what I can say I do remember
like when I was young my parents never
like like got me in trouble for showing
emotion or anything but I do remember
like my mom would go visit her parents a
lot and they lived out of state so we
didn't get to see them very much and
they would all be very sad when when we
would leave and I just remember thinking
like I'm going to be the one that
doesn't cry but I don't know why I don't
know why I thought that that was just
kind of in my head gotcha you showed
them huh I guess I I think I see it as a
sign of strength but I don't look at
people that show emotion as being weak
at least
not I don't know maybe deep down I
do so
I here's kind of my my
thinking emotions are shared in or
they're expressed in a variety of ways
and I've seen people who have really
awful things right like gnarliest of
gnarly friends loved ones whatever um
and they don't cry or they are go into
kind of a dark hole for four or five
days and they're kind of back out back
at it and I've had I've sat with people
and they're like dude everyone's telling
me like I'm gonna feel like this or this
is gonna happen or and it just doesn't I
just am kind of on to the next and so I
think that that is equally a valid
expression of your what your body is
working through is any other you know I
need to be out for five months um David
Kessler says grief is like a fingerprint
it's Unique to everybody right and so
once like your body's emo of expression
it's it's Unique to you what I would ask
is is this a way that you
either exert power in a
situation and I would challenge you on
like oh watch this I'm not going to cry
I'm going to stuff it so far down into
my soul just watch or you actually
didn't feel it like I'm I mean I'm sad
but I don't feel like like my body
doesn't feel like it it's going to cry
um or that's a superpower that you put
out into the world to protect yourself
now right so it's either a way to get
power or it's a way to defend
yourself and if it's not then great I
would tell you you have to have somebody
that you tell the hard stuff to that
doesn't mean you have to cry and kick
and
scream do you have that person those
people that's not your
spouse
yes are you honest with them kind
of I don't know that I share easily
that's okay I think we have a culture of
oversharing so I don't have a problem
with that at
all yeah I do I do I have a group of
friends that have walked through life
with so give me an example of a time you
shared what you were
feeling well okay to them so we me and
my husband went through a really rough
patch two years ago like not between us
but just in life I had some significant
health problems and stuff so I would say
like during that time I would share like
what was going on and stuff with them
would you share clinically like I've got
this ailment and this I'm taking this
medication or would you
say I'm scared our sex life is never
going to get back to way it was I'm
scared my husband's going to leave
me um probably in between that
okay yeah I would say in between that
okay sometimes people say I'm not very
emotional I don't like to share my
emotions and that's them giving thems a
pass on keeping secrets and those are
two different
things
okay I'm super okay if you don't wail
and kick and scream I'm a wailer and
kicker and screamer Kelly is not she's
not and in fact Kelly um and Kelly you
can pop in here I don't want to tell
your story for you but we talked about
how when she was diagnosed with with
breast cancer several years ago that she
spent most of her energy making sure
everybody in around her was was fine
that would beat me right
exactly
but that doesn't mean you get a pass on
sitting down with somebody and saying
hey I'm actually scared to death yes it
does it that was Kelly it doesn't
because um Secrets have a biological
toll they take on your
body so do you get the difference
between emotions and secrets as I'm
describing them I may not be doing a
good job yes no no no yeah no I think I
do okay so yeah dude I I here here's
what I would do I would spend 30 days
having a conversation with yourself in a
notebook do you do
that no because whenever you say that
I'm like how do people find time to do
that oh
sweetheart I have four little kids so my
time is about 30 minutes in the evening
before I go to bed to do all the things
I disagree with you that's the time you
allow
yourself okay
here I don't want to speak something
into the universe that's not true okay
cuz I don't want to send somebody on a
spelunking Expedition down into the
caverns of their soul for no reason but
it is not uncommon that somebody looks
at the world as it is laid in front of
them and as my friend Ian said simkin
says if busyness is your drug rest will
feel like
stress I don't have time I have this job
to do and this list to do and I will get
through the list and everyone has to eat
and everyone has to poop and everyone
has to wipe and all the dishes have to
be done and all of this has to be done
and what all of those tasks which do
have to get done they become a way to
not
feel and they become an
addiction because they allow me to be
busy instead of to
experience what I'm actually feeling
about all this stuff
because when you feel it and experience
it that's when you have a hard
conversation with your husband and say
hey I need some help around here or I
really wanted to be a mom and have four
kids and I'm burning out too and so can
we hire a house cleaner once a month or
can we can I work half a day once a week
so I can talk to adults about things
other than poo and
pee but if you don't ever give yourself
a
space which by the way give yourself
another 30 minutes for God's sake
right if you don't give yourself that
space your body is keeping the score the
whole time as VOR CK
says yeah that's probably true and then
one day you'll explode have you had a
good one a good just Rip Roar that
that's the thing is I hold it in and
then I will I will show my emotion in
probably anger or
frustration gosh you you know what you
could do for a living is be a producer
of pretty good podcast because you're
exactly like my friend Kelly
exactly
um here's what I I always I tell my
husband it's dangerous when I have time
to think because then like yeah like you
said you go down that Rabbit Trail it's
dangerous when you have time to think
it's deadly when you
don't that's a good
point so here's your challenge find two
or three things that you can ask him to
help around the house with and that
doesn't mean he's not working his butt
off at his job and that doesn't mean
he's not tired
either that means there's only so much
of you to go
around and give yourself 30 days to
write down in a journal in a
notebook and it could be as simple as
here's five things I'm grateful for
here's five things that I'm not grateful
for just be honest and it might take two
or three weeks doing this to slowly peel
back some of those layers my guess is it
was not
cool for you to cause a scene when you
were a
kid yeah I don't know I just didn't I
don't know if it was cold not I think
they would my parents would have been
fine with it but yeah no there was a
sense of like we act this way in the
culture we grew up in yeah so I get yeah
that's probably partly true and that's
not necessarily a bad thing right
but I don't want your kids feeling that
energy that nuclear reactor inside your
chest that's always kind of
buzzing that you don't deal with except
when it just overflows and becomes a
volcano in your living room I don't want
them Fe I'm people worry about that
explosion it's not great right when
yelling and screaming and slamming
cabinets or whatever it is you
do but that's not what I'm more mostly
worried about about I'm more worried
about the dayto day the perace the
pervasive
burn that's always there that those four
little kids are wondering 247 what am I
doing I love her she's so great she
never blows up at us she doesn't scream
or hit us but she doesn't feel
safe that's what I'm that's what I'm
hoping for and that doesn't mean you
have to scream and cry and have big
swings and all that everybody's
different when it comes to
that and it's okay if you don't want to
overshare you want to keep some things
private just to have a couple of people
that you're fully open with great that's
totally
awesome but there's a difference between
feeling there's a difference between
emotion and then end keeping
secrets my guess is if you make it a
regular practice to not keep secrets
from your husband to not keep secrets
from two or three close close friends
over time your body will feel permission
to
feel and to let some stuff go and to
drop your shoulders and to finally say
some things out loud like things that
you need and things that you're
frustrated by and things that you
love I'll leave you with this if you're
constantly stomping on the stuff you
don't have time to deal with I'm going
to time for
that then over time you're going to also
con unconsciously be stomping out
joy
laughter tons of
fun Reckless romance with your husband
those things get squashed
too and I want you to have it
all have it all thank you so much for
the call in mil you're
awesome